à à
anh
alo cho các bạn
thì các bạn đợi mình một tí để mình là
lên à
anh em lại cái danh này lấy cái Linh à
tính năng phòng Minh Ký
Ồ thông đăng ký làm toán
ừ giờ này chúng ta là hôm qua mình mới
nói giờ này ở trong ạ Lo chim thôi chứ
không hề có đăng bài thông báo gì cả
thế này có nhiều bạn thì sẽ thấy nó khá
là giấc rồi kể là không không biết lịch
các thứ như người ta nó không quan trọng
lắm Bởi vì thực ra lúc đầu thì mình
không phải đích là sẽ có buổi livestream
này mà sẽ là kiểu của chỉ chỉ là quay
soi thông báo riêng các bạn có Email
thôi nhưng mà thôi thì các bạn bảo muốn
nhìn thấy cho nó hồi hộp đúng ạ Cái tí
ra tôi chơi hẳn quay sổ xố Nga quay số
không biết có ăn mặn quyền không Ừ hi
vọng thôi có một bên nào đó vào đánh bản
quyền cơ hội nhạc xổ số sau đó thì tôi
sẽ cho trại ngẫu nhiên đúng ạ thì ở đây
thì ra là có có cả email nữa cả link
Facebook của các bạn đấy Hay góp ý thì
tôi xin phép ra ẩn người cái đấy Tôi sẽ
chỉ cho mấy ông xem có tên thôi để biết
được và tên của ai sẽ sẽ ra với ai
2007 không đăng ký xong rồi chẳng nhận
được cái gì đâu vì tôi có gửi cho mình
cái gì đâu Mấy ông nhận ạ
anh đợi tôi một tí nhé
à à
à À quên tôi lại không để cho mấy ông
thể tên ở đây rồi
à à
Ừ Ok Nếu thế thì à
Ừ thế thì mình cho theo à
chứ không phải chơi email email và hơi
nhạy cảm quá cho nick Facebook đi để bọn
sẽ ra mấy ông nhìn qua nick Face thì ông
cũng trừ khi mà ông gõ Thẳng lên trên
địa chỉ thì có thời gian nick Face người
ta nhưng mà thời gian làm chẳng chẳng
sao cả Không ạ Ông
nó không phải là một cái thứ gì đỏ nhạy
cảm với như email không ạ
có con nào đổi mail Thành chấm mail.com
này không test from đăng ký thuê Ok đi
xổ số thứ tự à Ừ thì đâu nhiên là gói
chuyện là số tự này với sự kiện kia thì
chắc chắn thôi nhưng mà ý mình là
các bạn sẽ
thì
các bạn đâu biết được số thứ tự bản thân
đâu đúng ạ
Ừ chị nói nhau rồi mà đúng ạ Các bạn
không biết là số tự bản thân nữa này ra
rồi các bạn sẽ chẳng biết được là mình
sẽ cùng nhau với ai nó vẫn thế thôi
ạ bây giờ đầu tiên là mình có danh sách
toàn bộ email mà đúng không ạ
ạ sau đó đi mình sẽ ghét
thì mình sẽ đoàn dù like cái danh sách
email với loạn cả lên sau đó thì tôi tết
vào thì sẽ ra cậu ông nào đó sẽ chung
với một ông đó đúng ạ
xu hướng dẫn hàng chưa
từ Hà Nội lên Face chứ tôi vừa nói lên
face nữa
à à
Ê mày tao có danh sách email danh sách
định Face như thế này
nghe có ông chấm com Mày Tôi sẽ tạo Xóa
mày đi
Ừ thế như này một loạt đúng à
đi
sói tôi sẽ copy
an toàn bộ này mấy ông theo như sinh
viên cũ của tôi
à À đúng rồi tôi tôi tôi nói trước lại
nhá Có phải bố trí nào nhiều hơn đấy lên
đến 60 60 bạn gọi đẹp luôn Không lẽ ông
nào ra
ờ ờ thử Thứ nhất là
tôi bảo sẽ đóng cái phom đăng ký này
không không - dòng đầu tiên nó thấy
thằng Thành vẫn là 60 đây à
bí thư thứ nhất là tôi bảo là tôi sẽ
đóng Phong đăng kí này vào tối nay đó
ngoại nhưng thực tế là tôi nghĩ là thực
ra là có nhiều bạn sẽ xem clip sau xong
rồi xem song clip này là sử vẫn muốn
đăng ký hạn thì cha tôi vẫn sẽ 10 Linh
nhưng mà nhưng mà ngay bây giờ ngay bây
giờ tôi sẽ quay thì và tôi sẽ ghét cặp
trước những cái cặp đấy sẽ được bảo vệ
và nói chung là sẽ được ưu tiên bảo vệ
chưa hiểu từ Huế có những người đăng ký
sau và đương nhiên sẽ phải ghép cặp sau
đó ngọn và sẽ mấy ông thì ra là mấy ông
còn chơi cái trò là kiểu mấy ông đợi
hiểu Mọi người ở ghép cặp hết rồi nó mới
đăng ký và Ngạn để mà Mấy ông sẽ ghép
cặp với bạn của mình
cho tôi tôi biết cũng béo có thể nách
bằng cách đấy bởi vì À bởi vì gần đây
phải có ba muốn bạn nhắn tin cho mình cả
trai lẫn gái bảo là kiểu em em một là em
thích là một mình hay là em muốn kiểu
làm với bạn của em thôi cho các thì
mình đều trả lời tất cả bạn ấy rồi Nhưng
mình muốn nhắc lại ở đây đó là các bạn
nên cái mục đích của cái đồ này Nó là
kiểu sao cho thực tế nhất có thể khi mà
các bạn đi làm nghĩa thứ nhất là nó sẽ
có áp lực thứ 2 là nó sẽ kiểu là đi làm
thì các bạn đâu chọn được đồng nghiệp
Nhưng mình đã từng nói rồi các bạn không
chọn đồng nghiệp sẽ thì các bạn gặp ai
đương nhiên là sẽ có người giỏi hơn mình
người dốt hơn mình Và thậm chí là người
bạn tại bằng mình ở ạ Cũng có đúng ạ anh
có thể hai người yếu không ngủ cặp với
nhau sôi tự nhiên lại thấy tất cả những
nhóm còn lại thì trong có phải là mạng
thế vợ chiều người ta kiểu sấp chẳng hạn
con mình mới học lập trình tự nhận chung
cùng với một đứa cũng mới học làm gì
nhưng cái vấn đề ở đây là mình không
chấm điểm đúng không ạ Mình không đánh
giá các bạn qua việc làm một cái sản
phẩm
bởi điểm số mà mình sẽ đánh giá các bạn
có việc và các bạn cố gắng đến đâu ra xử
là kiểu kể cả ông giỏi tôi sẽ bắt ông
làm những cái tính năng phải tính năng
khó phải những cái gì đó không khó phức
tạp Tí con bạn đơn giản thì tôi sẽ yêu
cầu rất là đơn giản kiểu cửa thế thành
ra là
tôi sẽ rất khắc khe với tất cả các nhóm
bộ phim bé cần nhấn mạnh này tính Tôi là
một con người không mở thiên vị này tôi
kể cả người thân của tôi tôi vẫn sẽ sẵn
hàng kiểu chửi ngon nếu mà ngu hay là nó
là nếu sai nên là sẽ không có chuyện
kiểu tôi thiên vị hay là tôi thân với ai
hơn
mọi thứ đều sẽ do công bằng và kể cả
giỏi hay rốt đối với tôi nó sẽ rất công
bằng bạn dốt bạn khó hiểu và tham Mát gì
tôi sẽ ra đát và bạn ra hỏi mà bạn kiêu
ngạo mạn khinh thường bạn cậu không nộp
bài đủ hay là bạn kéo Vân và Nguyễn Văn
thì tôi cũng sẽ phạt và và như tôi nó là
sau 3 lần nữa ông ạ sau 3 lần thì các
bạn sẽ
nếu mà ma lần mà các bạn không bị bịnh
cảnh báo hoa lần bạn sẽ không được bảo
vệ đoán dụng ngoại ý à à
Ý tôi nói qua vừa rồi chắc các bạn cũng
hình dung được rồi cũng thấy rất là áp
lực cũng sẽ rất thấy là
Công Minh Công Bằng đúng không ạ
anh đi về là tôi sẽ ngẫu nhiên ở đây
mới có thêm một bạn đăng ký đấy
ok
cái bạn đăng ký này tôi lại xin phép như
tôi vừa nói tôi sự xin phép và phải chấp
nhận là ghép các bạn sau chứ Hi còn thêm
một bạn đã đăng ký cùng Ok con không tạm
thời là như này đã ừ
[âm nhạc]
ở tạm tốt nhất đại nhà tắm suốt 30 bạn
cho đã không tí một ông xong rồi thêm
với ông nữa nhìn lên mái tóc
chúng ta phải chốt cho đã ạ
em đứng dân À
đây nói chung và cơ tạm Chốt rồi ạ lợn
có lẫn cả là
à
Tôi đang định nói rồi đó là mấy ông muốn
Nano bao nhiêu lần này ông muốn Nano bao
nhiêu này có trạm như thế với lớp cũ của
tôi rồi tôi cho mình Bọn nó chơi ba lần
lần 1 để mô đúng bạn lần hai cũng để mô
lần 3 là chốt đâu ạ nhưng mà đấy là đối
với lớp của tôi bởi vì lớp tôi thì bọn
nó biết lẫn nhau rồi bảo biết tên của
nhau rồi Còn bây giờ thì thực ra các bạn
còn chẳng biết lẫn nhau đúng không ạ Nên
là nên là kiểu quá Bây giờ mà cháu bạn
xem thì các bạn cũng chẳng biết được a
vì ai đúng ạ nên xem một thôi nhá Ok một
chút đúng ạ ạ
Anh nói rồi anh nói là làm đấy thích
khoát
ông kể
an
ninh Phương ở vị trí thứ 58 có thêm một
bạn nữa kìa có hai bạn này sẽ được cùng
nhóm nhau đấy cũng là thực ra là hai bạn
đấy là bảo chẳng biết nhau đó sẽ nó công
bằng tương đối rồi Ừ
Ok tôi sẽ gửi cho các bạn danh sách này
các bạn xem
xem sau bây giờ các bạn à Nhìn nhìn qua
đã nhá Tôi tôi dừng tôi sẽ rung lên rồi
tôi dừng lại cho các bạn vài giây để các
bạn nhìn qua nhé
các bạn nhìn qua là biết được cái đường
link của mình mà đúng ạ
à à
à
À
không không không thế này bị say mất rồi
Thế này là thành ra tôi tôi xin lỗi Hình
như thế này thì à thành ra là bạn Linh
dưới bạn Linh ở trên mất rồi chúng ạ
xe ô tô bị lỗi đấy đoạn này phải chia
đôi mình chỉ lấy một nửa thôi rồi già
nước một nửa
Anh xin lỗi rồi vừa rồi có cho đi mua đi
Ừ tao cũng thêm
thêm vài bạn này 63 đúng ạ 62 nghĩa là
32 nghĩa là tôi sẽ chỉ lấy 32 thôi rồi
Xin lỗi nha
Đây bây giờ mới chuẩn này đúng rồi bây
giờ mới phải luôn lại này
đi mua đi mua xin lỗi xin lỗi
à quên quên Quỳnh đã cái cái đoạn này à
phải bằng tool của mình ngon hơn nhưng
mà thôi Tôi dùng tạm tune trên mạng cho
nó công bằng với ông phải bận cố tôi đều
Lê
Minh Phương lại gần cuối này Chúc mừng
bạn
Ừ
đợi tí đợi tí nhá 32
[âm nhạc]
ah-64 Tại sao lại theo một bạn nữa đây
anh đợi tôi một tí có gì đó Sai sai ở
đây
12 này
hai đến ba
33232 cộng 32 nữa
có ai ngờ tôi
số 64 64 chia ra bị lẻ mới mà bạn rồi
à à Ừ
thôi cứ bị sao ấy à
khi phát sóng của xe máy
Em đang chốt phát tuổi ở 64 64 lại ra
bạn của 63 đúng ạ à
E63 - 2 là 31 Đúng rồi tôi lại lấy nhân
thành 333 vào sao 31
số 31 Đây
à à
từ nãy giờ do tôi chả Tôi đang thiếu ngủ
đây
Ừ
không sao linh this code cũng được các
bạn tự liên lạc được với nhau thôi
Ừ thôi nghĩa là này chắc chắn cho
ông nào vừa rồi đăng ký muộn thì tạm
chấp nhận sau nhé em
Ừ
đúng nhỉ 31
em vừa rồi là
anh vẫn đẩy ra hạn Mấy bạn này
Ừ thôi biến thị vô Dốt toán ơi à
đi khám rồi Chửi - cái chữ cái hay nhỉ
- cái hay quên mất với mấy cái dòng đầu
này cái dòng đầu này đây
à à
bộ phim sex
Anh Tuấn quái thân quá lần cuối
Anh hứa lần cuối
ừ ừ
Ừ hai đứa ngoại
32 Đúng chưa Đúng rồi đây
Ừ đúng rồi
có thêm hai ông theo hai người Ông đăng
ký ức
à à
cả hai hoài sẽ cùng một nhóm với tôi tôi
tôi không làm được nữa đâu nó kệ đấy hai
ông sẽ cùng một nhóm
anh em
em gửi tiền thanhsang với bạn gì đó
không ạ Kiều Trang với bạn ông dây d
Ngọc Tài Ngọc Tài Lam Ngọc Tài lắm Mát
Anh Tài Nguyễn này mạnh béo này
Có ai đi như thế này có đuôi là 791 với
Huỳnh Công Ừ Mấy ông gắn ai đi vào thì
cho không ai biết được linh của anh cũng
tốt
À thì ra là các bạn nên làm việc bằng ai
đi hơn để về sau các bạn vừa đủ user
name mình cái link này nó không nó dụng
ở đây là đun rồi đấy sẽ
Ở đời có bạn hả Phước 98 với bạn Linh
Phương 999 tại Trung ương 2 bạn
có một thêm một ông ID nữa 432 với Lê
Tuấn ra tôi chỉ đọc thôi thôi Tí kiểu gì
tôi sẽ gửi lại cho bé ông danh sách mà
Vì thế nên làm bể Ông cứ yên tâm Tôi
đang Chỉ lướt qua cho mấy ông nên lại
thôi
cô Nguyễn Thị p loại video đồng mạng
à à
à à à à
nghe
có ông sudo 1412
à à
Ừ
ok lại thêm hạ bà cùng với đăng ký ok Kệ
Ba bạn mới đăng ký tôi sẽ phân nhóm sau
trả tí thì tôi cũng sẽ
thì thông báo lên đây thôi ông ạ Nói
chung đại khái như thế nhé
link này thì tôi chưa Chị chưa chia sẻ
với ông được luôn bởi vì lên này nó con
thêm vài thông tin để cảm nữa tôi mới gì
để quay cho mấy ông cậu biết qua thôi
những ông là một người đăng ký đấy thiệt
mấy ông ạ ạ
chi tiết
khi đàn ông nào Alo 404
Ừ cái đại phá như thế thôi bây giờ sẽ
đến cái mục là một định hướng định hướng
mục cái đồ này tôi có hẳn đường link rồi
à
ở đây là cái đường Linh Hồi trước tôi
dậy mà chưa được với ông vào đọc thì mấy
ông được gặp chẳng hiểu gì đâu đến độ
chẳng lo Ế
em có cái á quy trình bảo vệ hòa này
Đã lâu lắm rồi tôi ghi cái này từ lâu
lắm rồi ok
ở đây thì độ đầu tiên là các bạn sẽ
ở đầu tiên là các bạn sẽ phải chọn đề
tài đúng ạ đề tài như như tôi đã nói là
mấy bạn sẽ có thể làm là trang web tin
tức tin tức hoặc cả bán hàng
ở đâu ạ
ờ ờ
các trang web bán tin tức thì chính thức
cái gì được bán hàng bán hàng giả dịp
được đừng có 18 + nữa hơi nhạy cảm quá
và các bạn thực ra có thể nghĩ thêm
những lý tưởng khác nhưng tôi khuyên là
đồ ăn 1 thì các bạn tạm chấp nhận làm
những cái đơn giản trước để mà các bạn
hiểu rõ về bài toán cả nếu mà đối với
các bạn đã học với tiếng Anh này rồi các
bạn làm chán chê mới cái cái này quá đơn
giản rồi các bạn rồi chẳng hạn thì các
bạn vẫn có thể chọn một cái đề tài gì đó
Trông có vẻ đơn giản rồi các bạn làm
phức tạp vào nên theo cửa ra diện mù mì
hơn là xong rồi nhiều tính năng và ngon
hơn này cũng được đề tài thì thôi vẫn
chỉ giới hạn để dài trong để đón một là
những cái đơn giản thôi không có bài
toán quản lý nghiệp vụ gì cả để ngoạn
không có quản lý không bài toán nghĩa vụ
Ê
mấy ông rõ ông ạ Không có Không hẳn là
đến cái phần mềm gì đó giả sử lại xem dự
báo thời tiết hay là phần mềm quay xổ số
ngoài Văn Vân không sẽ chỉ có chỉ có
những cái kiểu làm tại sao lại có hai
cái đề tài này bởi vì là tin tức thì nó
sẽ là một cái rất là cơ bản nó đầy đủ
tính năng xem thêm sửa xóa để má thì chị
ra cái những cái mà mình vừa thêm đúng
không ạ Cũng sẽ có mục bên quản lý ăn
min là để mà đăng bài sau có bên khách
hàng để xem lại cái bài đăng đấy đúng
không ạ sẽ có 2 đối tượng sử dụng tiếp
theo là bên bán hàng nó sẽ phức tạp hơn
một tí về bên bán hàng nó sẽ có tính
toán một tí nó sẽ có kiểu
nhiều bạn hơn và kiểu có liên quan đến
cả giỏ hàng Cái đấy là cái rất là hay
khi mà học là học mình phải biết qua về
cái kiểu về mảng thì nó sẽ liên quan đến
thảm mạng như ngoan các cặp thí sinh đây
là tôi nghĩ là thực sự là ai thực là tôi
muốn tôi muốn ít là tất cả các nhóm đều
làm theo cửa bán hàng
để mà các bạn biết qua về toàn bộ những
cái cơ bản đấy còn tin tức để dành cho
những nhóm kiểu nó kiểu khá hạ yếu kiểu
kiểu thế
sẽ mấy ông đừng có tự ti quá nhé đừng tự
ti quá là ai Ông là cũng chọn vì tin tức
thì ra là thế thì mình sẽ không ho không
họ được nhiều đúng không ạ tôi chưa biết
năng lực của mấy ông thế nào vì tôi
không dạy trực tiếp mấy ông thế là tôi
không thể ép công làm cái thứ gì cực kỳ
khó được nhưng mà tôi khuyên về không ạ
Nếu mấy ông muốn kết thúc khóa này theo
kiểu là hiểu hết toàn bộ về cơ bản thì
tôi tôi khuya là mấy ông biết về cái bên
bán hàng bán hàng này thờ ra là nó chỉ
xem thêm thử Xóa như cái kết hợp có thêm
cái giỏ hàng thôi chứ không yêu cầu các
bạn thì nó cao sieu làm như là thống kê
là cái gì có gì đâu chỉ ra đơn giản thôi
Lúc mà tôi dậy lúc mà tôi dạy Yến ta mà
tôi sẽ dạy hết tôi để mua hết cho mấy
ông thấy ai ghét gần như làm nông chỉ
cần xem video Gõ lại toàn bộ những cái
đấy đã ra đồng người sản phẩm đồ án rồi
cùng nhá Mấy ông trình sửa lại một vài
cái với giao diện này hay là trèo cốt
thêm tính năng có thử thôi
yên tâm mà khi tôi dậy thì ông ấy Ông ấy
ông sẽ thực ra nó không hưởng gì khó cả
tôi dậy hết nhé Không nói chuyện là kiểu
tôi vứt cho một đề tài được không tự đi
mà làm đâu không sẽ hết Đây là gần như
nhóm làm chỉ cần Xem lại video còn lại
cũng gần như ở đã có một cái sản phẩm
rồi nhưng bé đồ ăn bột rồi như thế thôi
đùa hay nấu người khác để ông ạ rất hay
Tôi không dành những người cố từ đầu đến
cuối cho mấy ông đâu
đấy thì thì bây giờ Nói chung à Hết buổi
hôm nay Tí tôi sẽ gửi cho ông Mười mấy
ông bảy cái link để với ông à Linh Lê
Văn Linh
Linh để cho mấy ông tự vào để mà xem xem
là mình sẽ kết tập với ai đúng không ạ
để mà
gì để mà trao đổi với người ta không ạ
Và
sau đó thì ta có ông chui được vào đây
rồi mẹ đi
A và sọ sau đó thì mới ông sẽ đến ngồi
nghĩ thể tài chọn đề tài đúng ạ thì
Ừ thôi tôi sẽ tôi đang không biết được
là tôi nên có một cái kênh à à
Anh thường mà nên có một kênh discord
nhà kiểu kiểu thế
phim hài kinh gì đó để mà liên lạc được
của mấy ông về mà chấm thường xuyên với
ông nữa
khi sex
à Tôi đang mấy bé uống thử có ý do xe mà
thử xem mà tôi nên nhắn tin với hôm qua
Facebook mà hay là discord được cấu tạo
một cái server riêng nữa so với riêng
nữa chỉ để kiểu ở để cho mụ Mỗi nhóm một
kênh để mà cậu mệt với ông sẽ thảo nếu
không cần thảo luận qua đấy nhưng mà sẽ
sáng tôi sẽ là người vào vào từng cái
nhóm đấy để mà hỏi hỏi mấy ông hiểu bây
giờ tiến độ đang đến đâu đến đâu rồi tôi
nghĩa dysport thì sẽ là ổn đúng không ạ
phim
hoạt hình nhóm Facebook thì thực ra là
những Facebook thì nó bị loãng mắt
A Gọi điện thế tôi tạo một cái this nhá
tags em thì nó sẽ không chia thì từng
kênh cho từng nhóm
Đúng rồi đấy cháu lại discord cho cho
hợp lý nhé Thì nói cho tôi sẽ tạo một
cái server discord rồi ạ rồi các bạn sẽ
có link này vào đấy đúng không ạ rồi tôi
sẽ sẽ cho từng bạn vào vào và từng cái
kênh riêng kênh đấy các bạn không cần
phải liên lạc với nhau có kênh đấy kênh
đề cốt là để tôi hỏi bài tập cùng mấy
ông thôi ông ạ
a smart smart thì tôi thấy thực ra ít
người dùng discord và snack thì nó bị
giới hạn tin nhắn đấy tôi nghĩa là nó
giới hạn 10.000 tin nhắn trong toàn bộ
có server nên tôi nghĩ là discord thì nó
không thời hạn cái phần tin nhắn đấy thì
tôi nghĩ anh hơn và các bạn dùng quen
hơn nhỉ
hệ thống kê tạo trước mắt thế nhé à
anh bởi vì mình đang làm online thì cho
thấy ra nó cũng có cái bất tiện kiểu gì
thế
ở
đó kìa
Ừ Thì
Ừ cái Tí độ sẽ ghi lại là
ông chủ nhật tuần sau các bạn chắc chắn
phải chốt được với nhau là cái việc à
chọn mày dày và cũng như là phân công
cho ai sẽ làm bên gì Giả sử là các bạn
chọn trang web bán hàng để ạ thì ai sẽ
là bên khách hàng Ai sẽ làm nên admin
đối ngoại Việt Nam mi nữ cho sáng sẽ
phức tạp hơn
đối ngoại và bên bán hàng Thì ra thế nên
nào tôi nghĩ là bên khách hàng thì sẽ
phù hợp cho
a cho bạn nào yếu yếu hơn một tí cần bạn
admin thì sẽ làm kiểu nó sẽ bị Hơi nhiều
việc không một tí đúng ạ nhưng mà tôi
cũng sẽ chia tôi cũng sẽ dừng giờ mình
sẽ bảo các bạn từng bạn là kiểu ví dụ
bạn này sẽ phải làm cái gì bạn kia sẽ
phải làm cái gì
A và các bạn cũng sẽ phải chuẩn phải
kiểu thống nhất về nho bầu bầu ra nhóm
chưa có nhóm trưởng với nhá Tưởng hai
người một nhóm nhưng Cả hai người đều
bằng các không sẽ có nhóm chưa nhóm
trưởng có đây là gì để ghi lại nhé
Nhóm chưa có quyền và quyền và nghĩa vụ
là gì quyền đó là Ừ nếu mà giống như là
cái hồi mà thôi
cho sinh viên mình làm đi thì quyền của
bạn nó trưởng nó cực kỳ lớn đó là có thể
ờ ờ đá vợ Kích đi chủ tịch kìa đá kiểu
thế bạn kia bất cứ lúc nào
đấy cái quyền hạn giờ to mà đợi nhiên là
quyền lợi đúng ạ quyền lợi
cho đương nhiên là nó sẽ được được yêu à
theo kiểu là điều là cộng điểm nhãn cái
gì đó nhưng mà bây giờ mình nó không làm
theo điểm thì mình sẽ làm theo kiểu được
y trước cậu thấy cái vốn là được yêu ai
cậu là tôi sẽ gần nhở tôi sướng Anh Nhi
nhóm trưởng nhiều hơn tôi không nghe
nhóm phó thôi chứ bây giờ bé ngồi cãi
nhau thì thôi nghe đứa nào đúng
ở nhóm trưởng bỏ làm thì thì ông một
mình muốn nhóm đúng không ạ ừ ừ
à à
cơ sở thì giống lúc đi làm nữa đi làm
thì thằng leader của của bà sẽ là người
toàn quyền Đông ạ Nó bảo gì không phải
nghe thế không ạ
ừ ừ
A và nghĩa vụ ở đây sẽ là nghỉ
nghĩa vụ ở đây quyền lợi và nghĩa vụ và
luôn đi kèm nhau không ạ đó là
phải ra sao
kiểm soát tình hình rất là
tôi giao cho nhóm của ông là kiểu tôi
tôi đã nói là từng nhóm sẽ khác nhau rồi
đó ngoại bởi việc có nhóm trình độ sẽ
rất là giỏi thì tôi sẽ yêu cầu tuần sau
phải làm xong cái abc xyz thay vì nhóm
yếu thì sẽ chỉ yêu cầu đơn giản thôi
Đúng đoạn trưởng thành ra là
thành ra là cái vụ
Tôi giao cho từng nhóm và sẽ khác nhau
thành ra là tôi sẽ phải hỏi từng trưởng
nhóm là tiến độ đang đến đâu rồi ông ạ
Các bạn sẽ phải luôn phải luôn trả lời
được cái câu đấy đừng bao giờ hỏi là em
không biết thằng kia đang làm cái gì
Ừ cái đấy là một cảnh cảnh cảnh báo luôn
ạ đúng ạ
Ừ thì tôi cho một mấy ông một tuần để
mày không tìm hiểu đấy ông ạ Hà
nộilinh đăng ký thôi quên chưa Ghi mẹ
rồi đợi tí thôi đi Mẹ Linh đăng ký nhé
link đăng ký không nhỉ
ừ ừ
Hai Số Phận phần mềm nguồn mở rộng
này để tôi tìm lại linh đăng ký cho mấy
ông đang xem nhé
ạ
sau đây có bạn kia trả lời rồi tôi tin
luôn
à à
đề
thi ờ cái cây ở đây tôi Tôi không nói về
nhóm nào yếu nhóm nào giỏi mà đúng ạ Tôi
chỉ nói là cả
các bạn tôi tôi giao cho các bạn làm làm
trong tuần này phải xong cái gì đúng
không ạ Các bạn sẽ phải luôn cái nhóm
nhiệm vụ của nhóm trưởng là phải luôn
thuốc được cái người kia Và nếu mà gần
đến hạn rồi mà ông kia không làm được
đâu ạ
Ừ thì thì phải báo lại sớm chứ không có
trường hợp là khi mà tội đến lúc kiểm
tra rồi mới bán là
em nói bạn kia từ đầu tuần rồi Như vậy
không nghe em không liên lạc được với
bạn đời luôn Vân lúc đấy thì toàn bộ lời
nói của nhóm trưởng sẽ không có tác dụng
gì cả
Ở đâu cũng vậy đi thôi ông ạ Cái này
đúng nghĩa khi đi làm mấy ông sẽ thế
người leader người ta sẽ luôn phải cập
phải ngoài việc là làm nghĩa vụ của mình
đó ngọn sẽ phải luôn luôn sao được cái
tình hình luôn kiểm soát được chứ không
bờ được nói cái câu là cậu em không biết
được gì đó đúng ạ và đương nhiên là nếu
mà cả nhóm mà không thì tiến độ thì cả
hai cùng phạt rồi nhưng mà nhóm trưởng
sẽ bị nặng hơn
ở những cái quyền của ông cũng sẽ có
nghĩa vụ ra to lớn đúng ạ
khi
bé ông hiệu na ná đoạn này chưa ạ Có ông
nào có thể ăn được hơn chưa
cô bạn kia biến mất thì em cũng phải có
nghĩa vụ là báo lại cho anh sớm không
thể đến lúc mà kiểm tra rồi mới báo thì
anh vừa nó dậy thì chắc chắn là cái đấy
là lỗi do em chưa phải lỗi do bạn đấy
mạng kia biến mất thì
Ừ thì phải báo sớm trước be tried ít
nhất là một hoặc hai ngày đúng ạ không
thể báo lúc mà kiểm tra được
Ừ lúc đấy thì các bạn đi làm ngoài tới
nó thế Đúng rồi sẽ không có kiểu là đến
lúc mà kiểm tra lúc mà kiểu kiểu Gặp đối
tác mới bắt đầu kiểu
em giao việc này cho bạn a b c nhưng bạn
đấy chưa làm nói câu đấy thì đối tác nó
sẽ nói gì đúng ạ
à à
khi tôi Thực ra tôi không khắt khe với
vụ mấy ông Sắp xong em bị ông cậu tự
nhiên tuần này có việc thi hay có có
việc gì đó mày ông cậu chưa làm xong thì
không sao nhưng mà nhưng mà Cái quan
trọng là cái cách cách kiểu cài gọi là ý
thức và và kiểu
nói chung là tôi nghĩ là mấy ông cũng
hiểu gì tôi mà đúng ạ
à à
anh không thể tải vừa rồi là bạn cái Hỏi
với chị em nữa tôi tôi bị Hương biết
xưng là anh đấy chứ Thật ra tội chỉ xưng
hô tôi với mình thôi chứ
Ừ đúng rồi cố gắng mà làm không đối phó
ông kia nói chuẩn đấy Nghĩa làm gì cả
Tôi không khắt khe với nỗi là kiểu giảm
chưa thầy cô trên lớp của mấy bạn tôi
làm gì có quyền gì cả đúng đó thôi chị ạ
một cái ông trên mạng nó nhằm được nhiều
người xem trở lại đấy
nhưng mà mấy ông sẽ phải kiểu Đây là họ
cho mấy ông mấy ông đăng ký là thực ra
nó là cái kiểu mà ông phải có trách
nhiệm với cái nhóm của mấy ông trách
nhiệm với cái việc học đấy Bây giờ nó là
miễn miễn phí Tui là tui là kể cả các
bạn làm được rất là rất là ổi thì tôi
cũng chưa chắc tôi thưởng được cho các
bạn cái gì nhưng mà cái này là nó là học
đúng cho các bạn nó học nghề cho các bạn
luôn nên các bạn sẽ tự hiểu là các bạn
sẽ phải cố gắng như thế nào đúng hạn vân
vân Vì thế nên là nếu mà các bạn có một
vấn đề gì đó kiểu bị thứ cũng có mà kiểu
gì chẳng sẽ có một vài bạn bị tự nhiên
là vấn đề về Học hành kiểu đấy là gì Vân
vân sẽ không sẽ không hoàn thành được
thì hoàn toàn tôi thông cảm với vụ đấy
như các bạn phải báo sớm không có chuyện
là hiểu đến lúc mà kiểu kiểm tra rồi mới
báo thế từ đầu tuần đến cuối tuần thì
ông Làm gì mà đến cuối tuần ông bị báo
đúng ạ Thế nên là cái đấy hoàn toàn là
lỗi do bạn đúng không ạ
em không có lý do ngụy biện vì cho cái
đấy K
em
nghe cái này đi xong thấy ổn không thấy
nó kiểu có còn vấn đề gì Thắng mau
ừ ừ
anh
không thoáng mát thì tiếp tục nhé đi Chị
Thơ ca những ngày dưới này ghi ở dưới
này thì cái này thì về sau mình sẽ hướng
dẫn các bạn về viết tài liệu thì mấy ông
với mới các bạn mới biết cách làm cái
cái vụ này Nhưng mà đại khái thì các bạn
sẽ xảy ra quy trình bảo vệ đoán sẽ nói
qua tất cả những cái kiểu những ngày nay
sẽ là có cả đời mô ở trang web nghĩa là
các bạn sẽ mở slide lên để nó chai qua
về những cái kiểu các bạn hãy chuẩn bị
những cái gì với Vân sau đó thì các bạn
sẽ có thực hành nữa là các bạn sẽ mở
trang web các bạn lên chia sẻ màn hình
không cần chia sẻ mặt đâu Tôi không quan
tâm mặt của mấy ông đâu thì sẽ mở chia
sẻ màn hình để mà các bạn sẽ demo thực
tế từ bên bên của bạn là khách hàng
trước chả nạn sau đó thì bên admin sẽ
làm những gì các thứ đương nhiên là gần
đến hôm bảo vệ tôi sẽ được nhờ tôi sẽ
phải hướng dẫn các bạn thêm lần nữa
người tất cả những cái này giờ tôi đang
định hướng các bạn để ý chào các bạn Hôm
nay có thắc mắc bất kỳ vấn đề gì thì các
bạn hỏi luôn và tôi sẽ trả lời trước
đúng lại để để các bạn hình dung được
Ê bà Kiểu thấy tự tin hiểu thấy à
anh tự tin tự tin hơn về cái việc tham
gia đồ án này đúng ạ Chứ bây giờ vẫn còn
Mưng lông gì đó như là không dám Không
dám bước lên cái con thuyền đấy đâu đúng
không ạ đây làm con thuyền nó không
không không hẳn là đi êm đềm nó lắm nó
cũng sẽ coi sóng gió đi thế chả là nếu
mà các bạn bạn nó đến cuối thì nó sẽ đến
đảo đã thiên đường ấy đạo Địa Ngục Thì
Tôi không rõ ý
Ừ ok
Ừ cái link tham khảo đồ án này các bạn
thích có thể xem qua nữa tôi có để ở đây
thì à thật hay tài liệu mẫu không biết
nó lỗi nữa à
ở bên đấy là tôi làm cái cái này cho
sinh viên của tôi
Ừ nhưng mà
cái này các bạn vẫn có thể hoàn toàn
tham khảo để mà các bạn xem vì về sau
tôi sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn làm tất cả
những cái này đó ngoại em không có
PowerPoint đấy đâu mà Mấy ông sẽ về từ
Word để làm Powerpoint
Ê mày có bạn bảo vệ online như này thì
không phải in cái wed like nhé Còn sinh
viên của tôi là Thơm
tôi sẽ bắt phải inward ra để mà kéo để
in ra là thành quyền tài liệu ý Để mà
nộp cho các thầy cô để mà các thầy cô
kiểu sẽ ngồi dưới để xem để mà vừa xem
vừa hỏi các bạn luôn
Ê bà thậm chí là nếu mà bảo nếu mà bảo
vệ tốt nghiệp
khi tốt nghiệp thì các bạn sẽ phải đi là
cái quyển khiến các bạn với quyển đoán
tốt nghiệp chùa án tốt nghiệp à
ở đây là các bạn sẽ bị in quyền này cái
kiểu như này tội mua cái đôi màu này khá
là đẹp chuyện gì thế
cho tôi hình như tôi để sử chiến trường
mà để hôm nào tôi bảo đồng nghiệp của
tôi lên bác xử với quyền lấy về để tôi
sẽ hôm mà tôi sẽ quay video trong máy
ông ấy mày không xem tôi khẳng định tôi
có thể là văn tôi không tốt lắm nhưng
tôi biết cách trình bày và tôi là con
người từ đầu đến cuối là trận Trì tiến
hành ra cái ghi Word bị tài liệu của tôi
nó không thường một dấu cách nào đã Nó
không nó căn lề đều phải chuột cỡ chữ
phải giống hệt nhau nói chung trong rất
là chuẩn trong nó rất là kiểu như một
cuốn sách ở đây tôi khẳng định được ý
chứ còn nội dung thì có thể là đương
nhiên là mình cũng đi tham khảo trên
mạng thôi
em có nội dung tham khảo trên mạng thì
về Nói chung về sau tôi dậy cấp bậc Ông
viết word thì đừng dễ triệu dần cái cái
vụ đấy ý
ờ ờ
nó có mạng thắc mắc gì nữa không nhỉ
ở các buổi hôm nay nó sẽ chỉ thương đời
này thôi bảo là phân nhóm nữa và định
hướng và giải đáp tạm trước các thắc mắc
rồi cáo ạ Các bạn có góp ý gì này hay là
thắc mắc gì thêm thì hỏi thôi
Vì vậy tôi xem con slot vào discord
không thôi tôi chưa Tạo tí rồi tạo Tôi
sẽ để ở bình luận của video này mấy ông
tí ra hợp lý có lại nha chú ý
ông thầy kiểm tra và cuối tuần đúng thầy
Đúng rồi mình sẽ định là kiểm tra vào
chủ nhật cuối tuần đi để cho mình cũng
rảnh và các bạn cũng sẽ cậu sẽ cần thoải
mái áp lực từ đầu tuần nó kiểu bị ám ảnh
du lịch livestream anh được livestream
của mình là 35 tội tội nó ngoài bạn kia
vào đấy Tối 8 giờ 357 chẳng qua là hôm
nay
mình muốn nó qua một cái vụ đồ án này
thôi
chi tiết
Ừ tí mình cũng sẽ bình luận cho các bạn
về cái vụ Linh toàn bộ cái link này sao
mà có thêm hai bạn nữa rồi này sẽ không
lại thấy bạn nào này kê
chi tiết
Ừ để tôi tôi xin phép tôi ngồi lướt qua
tất cả bình luận thì tôi trả lời hết
ý theo dõi nhé
cô bạn kia chưa làm được nhưng lúc
leader hỏi vẫn bảo sắp xong rồi thì sao
ạ
1000 cái việc này vẫn là lỗi của rò
leader thôi các bạn sẽ không thể hỏi
bằng mồm được các bạn sẽ phải kiểm tra
các sự thứ đối ngoại các bạn hỏi bằng
mồm thì các bạn lại say rồi đấy việc của
leader không phải là cư Đặt báo thức thì
cậu lại gần đến cuối tuần hỏi xem bạn
kia làm xong chưa không các bạn làm việc
lập trình các bạn sẽ đôi khi các bạn còn
sạch phải ghép cốt nữa nghĩa là
bạn kia phải gửi cốt cho các bạn để ghét
chẳng hạn do Vân Các bạn cũng sẽ phải
chạy thử lại xem mua một cái không các
thứ thứ xung đột hay không nên là không
nói chuyện được hỏi nhau bằng Mồm với
bạn Mày làm xong phần A chưa ra làm 6
phần B rồi đấy Cái dư thôi Đến đã từng
có nhiều nhóm như thế mà đến gần đến bảo
vệ đoán mới mới hiểu mới tá hỏa lên lúc
mà tôi kiểm tra kỹ lại
anh Bởi vì gà Hồi đấy tôi dậy thì công
nhận là Hồi đấy tôi mới chạy nên tôi
không lường trước được là tôi tôi cứ hỏi
tôi cứ hỏi một ông Nghị ông ấy công nhận
ông ấy cho tôi xem phần ông ấy làm gì
Đúng như ông rồi rồi Ông kia thì mở thì
sẽ phần kia rồi nhưng mà thôi đấy Tôi
quên mất dịch vụ là kiểu miếng phải ghép
lại nữa thành ra gần đến hôm bảo vệ đồ
ăn với Bắt đầu ghét rồi ghét thì lỗi
chắc chắn lỗ rồi bởi vì Đến gần cuối vớ
ghét mà đúng ạ
Không không leader không có nhiệm vụ là
phải ghép cốt mà mà leader sẽ chỉ có
nhiệm vụ ở thúc người kia đó Ngoại còn
nếu mà tôi bảo rồi bạn kia mà làm cố vấn
đề gì đó mà ông thấy 025 ông cứ báo lại
sau đó thì ông có thể cho ông kia bị bay
màu hướng nào mua khi bay màu của tôi
không cho sang nhóm riêng hay là kiểu
đực bảo vệ lại rồi nhé
em à không có bảo vệ lại như sẽ bảo vệ
Nói chung đợt 2 đợt 3 gì đấy Nói chung
là không bảo không được bảo vệ cùng các
bạn đừng buồn nữa
thôi chưa dậy mày không phải ít nhưng mà
Mấy ông biết trước về nghĩ thì càng tốt
đón một thì được ca Cốt nó cũng không
tương đối dài làm đâu đấy mấy ông tìm
hiểu với ít chứ
ừ ừ
Ừ Ừ
nhưng mà mày ông chắc là cũng biết qua
về get hấp dẫn đi để mà khi mà tôi yêu
cầu mấy ông cho tôi xem cốt để mà xem
xem Cốt Đây không phải tôi đi ăn trộm
cốt của mày không có nhé Xem cốt ở đây
là để cho tôi xem qua là mấy ông cốt
đang có ổn hay không ổn ở đây là về à tự
sắp xếp thư mục cốt này đặt tên biển này
do Vân Vân Vân music thì có vẻ ổn Đấy
chưa cần phải sửa loại nào không Tôi
nghĩa tôi chấm dọn lại tốn khá nhiều
thời gian cũng như cũng đau não đấy đúng
không ạ ạ
anh nói chung là cái cái khóa này của
tôi thì vẫn chưa dậy các bạn về dùng đi
Thấp
cho
nên là tôi
Ừ thôi không muốn các bạn kiểu phải phức
tạp quá về vụ là con flix2 mất này có
nhờ bạn còn chưa biết là vụ đấy
bởi vì nó vẫn về cơ bản thì nó vẫn ý
thôi rồi vẫn ít cốt để mình các bạn có
lại Complex khi các bạn làm tách riêng
phần thì sẽ không gần ngựa sẽ không có
kiểu như thế nó chỉ là liên quan việc
vậy không còn fake mà việc là khi mà các
bạn ghét cốt vào thì thì
sợ ở cậu vấn đề gì đó không chạy được
thôi
anh nói chung là bây giờ thì trước mắt
thì châm có vẻ là ba mươi mấy nhóm đúng
không ạ Rồi cũng nhiều phết đấy Buồn hồi
mình đi Dậy thì ạ một lớp thì chỉ có tâm
mà 15 16 nhóm Thôi thì ở đây nha bằng
hai lớp rồi hai lớp của tôi dậy rồi
Ừ thì chắc là la
hai lớp à Chắc chắn là một buổi một buổi
để mà bảo vệ đồ án cũng có khi không thể
xong rồi à
Ừ chắc phải livestream từ từ sáng đến
tối à
ẩm
thực làm mình mình không biết mình nói
các bạn chưa là mình gần đây mình mới đi
làm ở công ty kiểu dạng chuyên nghiệp từ
trước nay thì mình đã ở
từng từng cũng từng đi ở công ty rồi
Nhưng mà nó không hẳn chưa nghiệm làm
kiểu làm kiểu vớ vẩn đó cậu rảnh hả tôi
cứ đầy cốt đến hồi tội không biết dịch
vụ còn flix2 vụ các thứ anh không biết
rồi cặp gen khác canh khác làm hỗ trợ
hết cho tôi vụ đấy rồi
Ừ thế là gần đây tôi mới biết về cái vụ
hiểu đầy đủ tương đối các tính năng của
bên get up nhưng mà tôi cũng chỉ vẫn chỉ
mới tiếp xúc với nó đấy là tôi sẽ không
dậy các bạn được mình đấy nhưng các bạn
sẽ phải tham khảo về việc dùng ít hấp
chuẩn là trên mạng
à còn đồ ăn hay ở chất thành Tôi sẽ dạy
các bạn về huyết áp nhưng mà cũng sẽ chỉ
dạy mức cơ bản thôi
ừ ừ
Xin chào tất cả công ty tôi từng tham
gia thì đều là làm khô đắp
ô ô ngoài trưng bày Tôi cũng đang nghĩ
việc ở trần bài Tôi sẽ rất là bị lười
đây bởi vì thức thực sự thì gần đây Tôi
nói các bạn rồi là gần đây Hồi trước Và
tôi chạy đêm nay ở trên công ty ghê lắm
một tuần tôi xong rồi chụp công việc cơ
như gần đây Đúng là sếp bảo Dạo này em
bị mất tích à Có thể vừa thôi Có vẻ bị
Hơi bị sao nhãng có tập trung vào cả bên
bên cô biến mình có
Ừ bia mấy ông nghĩ sao nào ạ sau một
tuần anh chỉ tốn cần 3 tiếng buổi tối
không ạ Mỗi buổi một tiếng nhưng mà
không sẽ tôi không Tôi không soạn bài
đâu vì toàn bộ những cái này tôi đã từng
dậy rồi tôi gần như thuộc lòng rồi nhưng
tôi không soạn bài nhưng mà vừa tội trấn
bài này và cũng cũng phải xem lại video
rồi cũng nghĩ cũng nghĩ về nó nghĩ về nó
gì nhiều
không biết các bạn học lập trình xong
các bạn có bị kiểu Ám Ảnh như tôi không
Tôi học lập trình xong tôi bị ám ảnh
theo kiểu nó là ám ảnh trong ngoài đam
mê nữa kiểu là tôi ngủ tao vẫn mơ về cái
đoạn bất vạn cốt các thứ thứ nhưng gần
đây tôi đang tôi ngủ rồi không mơ về cốt
ở trên công ty nữa Tuy mơ và cách dạy
học cơ thành ra là não Nói chung là tôi
đang bị khá bị phân tâm là như thế
ừ ừ
ở bài ever đấy có nhiều cái câu
số câu trả lời ở trên là tách cái bồ
nhưng mà tôi vẫn chưa trả lời trả thì
thôi xem lại
3000 một nhóm thì nên chỉ có hai bạn
thôi Bởi vì sao Bởi vì một bạn làm bên
admin 1 bạn là miếng khách hàng chứ nếu
không một nhóm ba người ta làm mấy ông
chẳng biết được bạn thứ ba sẽ làm gì
đúng ạ À đúng rồi đó là tôi dậy mấy ông
về lập trình nghĩa là mấy ông ai cũng sẽ
phải biết VP để ông ạ Ai cũng sẽ phải
thuyết trình
a bít nhất bạn yếu nhất cũng phải làm
được đầy đủ tính năng thêm sữa xóa của
một bạn bất kỳ chứ tôi không Tuyển mấy
ông theo đó tôi không cho mấy ông làm
như một ông làm file mùa ông hoàng bán
nghe nữa nhé không nói chuyện là một ông
làm chỉ mỗi giao diện và một ông thì làm
toàn bộ bên xử lý do nhé
bởi vì tôi chấm là tôi chấm mấy ông
theo về lôgic và lập trình chứ không
phải là trăm mấy ông về thiết kế đúng
không ạ tôi không có tâm lý giao diện
đâu
à à
3000 cài bên tách tách riêng ra rồi thì
sẽ toàn là sẽ sẽ cũng hiểu từ đầu đến
cuối của một cái rồi đứng yên à
Nếu mà bạn làm bên khách hàng thì bạn
nghĩ là bạn đấy không làm tính năng thêm
sữa xóa đúng không Không mình nói với
khách hàng đấy Em chỉ là cũng sẽ phải
thêm sửa xóa mà bảo bất kỳ mà không ạ
yên tâm mà tôi sẽ chia cho mấy bạn kiểu
gì Các bạn cũng sẽ phải biết tướng tung
tương đối một cái gì đó
du lịch sử là bạn bên admin nhưng bạn
đấy do hỏi thì bọn đấy sẽ phải làm bên
giỏ hàng bạn bè giỏ hàng thì nó sẽ phức
tạp các kiểu đó là mạng kết hợp với cả
thí sinh con con bạn là yếu vừa rồi thì
bạn đấy có thể làm chỉ Dạ tính năng Đăng
nhập đăng ký bởi vì nó sẽ là kiểu nó sẽ
có liên quan giữa rừng nhưng mà không
mức độ không phải là khó đúng ạ yên tâm
tôi tôi dạy cái tôi dậy về đoán thì chắc
ạ
thì nó sẽ đợt đi Nói theo đợt thì chắc
là phải
mỗi năm thì hai đợt tôi dậy được 3 năm
rồi
khi cha 6 đợt 6 7 đợt từ ấy về hồi đấy
Cho còn đi tập cũng dậy rồi Thế là tôi
có kinh nghiệm về cái đồ án này rồi
có kinh nghiệm ở đây là kinh nghiệm cả
kinh nghiệm xương máu Nó theo kiểu đấy
cũng có vài nhóm đã từng kiểu cũng không
ổn bởi vì là do cách cách hướng dẫn của
mình có vấn đề đến gần cuối thì người
biết được như vậy sao có nói là tôi phải
rút kinh nghiệm rất nhiều đấy rồi
khi nào bắt đầu á thì thôi để link cho
mấy ông link discord này xong rồi bê
tông tự ghép cặp này rồi tôi sẽ tạo nhóm
Mời Mời ông vào cái từng kênh một đúng ạ
gồm mấy ông sẽ che ở trong đấy rồi chát
Nói chung là làm cái gì làm để mà tuần
sau tôi sẽ chốt đây có ghi lại chỗ cái
gì nhé Chủ nhật tuần sau này
suốt
đề tài à
Em
ngủ chưa
nhóm trưởng thì không cần nhất thiết
phải là giỏi hơn chẳng qua là người đấy
cần này nói được người kia ở đâu ạ nhóm
trưởng không cần thiết phải giỏi tôi
không yêu cầu cái vụ đấy ngắm trường hôm
nay ở cần phải quản lý được ông ạ Mấy
ông thấy quản lý về thực tế các xét về
sẽ chưa chắc đã giỏi xếp Chị giỏi và
quản lý do này
ai là người làm ăn Min Ai là người làm
Khánh Hà ý
hai tuần sau thì ra tội sẽ dạy cho các
bạn thế à
à à
mẹ bệnh tôi tôi hôm trước tôi dậy các
bạn về cái phân à
Đa phần là chia bố cục của một trang web
bởi lao rồi đúng ạ Nên là chặn toàn Tuần
sau tôi sẽ nói thêm cả bên khách hàng
nữa đây là tuần sau gửi cho tôi sẽ yêu
cầu các bạn làm luôn cả giao diện
khách hàng và giao diện admin giao diện
diện khách hàng đây sẽ cần là trang chủ
còn giao diện admin thì sẽ là kiểu dạng
cũng là trang chủ thôi
cả hai đều là sao cho đủ
Ừ nó diện admin thì cần nhiều chủ yếu là
sẽ là có menu đúng ạ cần Như là menu
phút tơ gì đó Hoàng đơn giản các bạn nó
thu
cô giáo dạy amin đơn giản hơn khá nhiều
có giao diện của khách hàng thì các bạn
sau này chia bố cục theo kiểu
yêu cầu như này thôi cho mấy ông xem một
cái đề mô giao diện khách hàng ở trong
cách bán hàng nhé Đợi tí đi
Anh không biết nó có đang chạy không
ở đại Kèo Nhà Cái này đương nhiên là cái
này là giao diện tôi ăn cắp về thì thành
ra là nó trong nó đẹp như các bạn Dung
rồi Nó là kiểu logo rồi xong ngồi trên
là thanh menu trắng ạ dưới các sản phẩm
này nó ngoác dưới footer kiểu như này
đấy thì tương đối đây là giao diện của
khách hàng thì các bạn cần làm như này
đúng không ạ
à à
Ừ đấy thì thì các bạn đang thấy thì cái
ông ông làm bên khách hàng thì có vẻ
tặng cốt yếu hơn thì sẽ phải bù đắp một
tí bằng tốn nhiều công sức để làm về
giao diện còn ông làm ăn Min thì sẽ vậy
sẽ phải làm những cái kiểu
Kiều sẽ liên quan đến xử lý số tạp hơn
ngoại tình yên tâm tí về sau tôi sẽ chi
việc ra trong đấy ông để mấy ông luôn
không có tí lạnh nhau nếu sẽ thấy công
bằng thôi
à à
Ừ ông ông kia vẫn còn hỏi việc là decal
web hay tự thiết kế thì tôi tôi không
Tôi không muốn mấy ông đi copy code mà
ông sẽ đều phải đều phải tự chốt từ đầu
đến cuối cả tìm rcs không được dùng
Wechat không dùng về sau có thể áp dụng
Yuri nếu mà các bạn làm xong đầy đủ
tương đối các tính năng rồi
của chung các bạn có thể dùng các thư
viện được Nếu không được dùng word
khi nó diễn admin Thì hôm trước mình có
định mình có cho bạn xem rồi mày ạ
xe tải amalfi thì nó sẽ lại nó sẽ ra
kiểu một cái dashboard thì cậu đi làm mà
Ừ nó cũng sẽ cậu menu menu ở bên trái
này sau đó thì
Ở đây mức tương đối thôi nhé sau đó thì
trên này có thể có không thường chơi này
không cần có được phút tơ ở dưới không
cần có được tính nhất là cũng phải tương
đối như thế này đúng ạ
anh
khóc không View Gia thì cả chỉ GS phần
thôi t Thuận
chú ý
a a rất là có trong zu đấy thì các bạn
sẽ đồ dùng sau khi mà các bạn làm có vẻ
tương đối các tính năng rồi thì mình sẽ
cho các bạn áp dụng thêm
khi hát xong kia muốn bảo đào template
vậy không Cốt còn đi Cố tuần cho quen
bởi vì cái khóa này là khóa tổng hợp cả
hplc hát nữa mà mình các bạn cũng phải
cốt thuần tí htl CF anh không cần yêu
cầu các bạn giao diện đẹp đâu mà các bạn
chỉ còn biết cốt Tôi tôi muốn với ông là
để không Cốt lại việc làm menu cốt như
thế nào này đúng không ạ xong rồi chia
bố cục của các đít đủ như thế nào Chẳng
mấy ông vừa tệ Tải template về lại nhà
nước mới hôm qua
mà
SS SS thì nó là
bị không như hỡi Cái Khái niệm và lắm
nhưng mà hình như
trả lại
A B C S thì như nói chuyện ở một cái
kiểu ta nói nó là kiểu xử lý xét bố xơ
Nó là kiểu biến xe thành ngôn ngữ lập
trình đây là nó nó không không hẳn làm
cái gì đó Facebook hay là một cái gì đó
đâu Nên là các bạn thực ra dùng cái này
cũng được không sao cả
về bản chất là cái này nó sẽ là kiểu cốt
CS Nhưng mà theo dạng khác cơ mà
Ừ đúng rồi các bạn sẽ phải nói chung là
đây đồ án Cơ bản ông làm 4 sấp thì ông
bắt buộc phải làm cơ bản cho tôi ông
không thể làm xuống xuống đây Smart mấy
ông cứ trôi những cái sĩ do nhất về khoe
được mấy ông phải nếu mà ông muốn thể
hiện trình độ là mình không phải làm
được cái cơ bản mà trông có phải hàng
xịn Ở đây mưa ở
đây mới gọi giỏi đúng
chị còn đoán hay đoán về quét nâng cao
thì tôi không hề giới hạn được mấy ông
ấy muốn làm bất cứ cái gì mình không ạ
tôi dậy cho mấy ông lario mày không chơi
bất cứ cái gì nữa tội không quan tâm để
ngoạn Nên là nếu mấy ông thực sự là kiểu
muốn áp dụng đủ thứ thì mày học đội sang
đón hay đoàn sau khóa sau còn khóa này
tôi chỉ dạy cho nghiệp dân nghiệp dư
thôi
Ừ thế đủ giải quyết mọi thắc mắc của mấy
ông chị
ba lần này vẫn Chốt rồi nhá hôm mà tôi
tôi mà xem cốt với ông mấy ông ngồi cốt
mà mà không không như tôi vừa nói thì
thì tôi lại một cái cảnh báo đấy thôi
nhớ thôi thôi Nói chung là tôi sẽ ghi
lại từng nhóm cách làm nha à
ở đây này cái này trước mắt chủ nhật
tuần sau thôi ông ạ
cho chủ nhà thì chất sao tôi không phải
sáng sớm mày tao tự nhiên hỏi các bạn
rồi tôi sẽ nói cho tôi sẽ nhắn tin ở
trong ngày chủ nhật sau đó thì cần trong
ngày chủ nhật đấy các bạn phải trả lời
cho tôi
ở Trung Quốc
vì thế tóc miseen
anh cũng tương đối đúng không gần một
tiếng thôi
mở cốp nhìn xấu cốt nhìn xấu ở đây án
chỉ các bạn với giao diện xấu hay là cốt
của ông Trông tồi thước cờ ông không
dùng nhiều cách nó không dùng nó tát rồi
ạ Ông có viết hết trên dòng à
Em bán cả cốc nhìn xấu và đôi khi là cốt
trong rối này đặt tên biến loạn hết cả
lên này thì cái đấy Có thể tôi sẽ chấm
cho mày không tệ đấy đi
anh nói chung là tôi sẽ tra được mệt à
nộp Đình Ký thấp phải rõ ngay sau mấy
ông cậu Nếu không cần à
Ừ nếu không cần là phải phải cố đăng lên
hosting có thứ thử đâu như tôi hôm trước
có nói ra nó hơi những cảm đi nhưng
Thanh Nga mấy ông cứ gửi gửi link kết
shop để cho cái kênh đấy để để để tôi sẽ
phải tải về mà chấp nhận thợ thủ công
một tí sẽ tải về nên là tôi nên là các
bạn sẽ phải nộp về sau còn phải nộp cả
gửi Gửi kèm
file word nữa vì sau các bạn sẽ phải gửi
thêm kem đó Này nhá để mặt tôi tải về
thôi còn chạy được không ạ
Ừ chốt là phải nộp ở giao diện đấy nhá
chứ không phải là chốt ở đây mỗi cái này
đâu làm cả giao diện luôn đi bởi vì mình
không cũng Hôm trước mình đã dạy các bạn
tương đối với cách chia bố cục của màn
không ạ Tuần sau tôi để hướng dẫn các
bạn về làm giao diện khách hàng như nào
nữa do diện đây có thể chỉ đơn giản là
sẽ các bạn chỉ cần tìm môn thôi này tôi
quên chưa ghi đến mua thôi Bởi vì a Có
thể tôi chửi yêu cầu các bạn làm đầy đủ
tính nam thêm sửa xóa chứng thì ra là là
chưa cần phải có sản phẩm chưa cho cần
có kiểu
kiểu cầu dạng là còn có nhiều sản phẩm
hiển thị liên lạc lên ở đấy hay là cái
gì đó như chị đấy trẻ để mô thôi nghĩa
là các bạn tạo trước mấy cái đít rồi sao
còn những cái ảnh trước những cái sản
phẩm để môi trước
Nếu hình do họ nó không biết cái không
nó diện Không
dùng thì không đi nhé anh
không này à
em được mấy ông kia ông kia dụng mai về
chân cũng được
10 tuần sau nộp trước ngày nay còn tuần
sau nữa tôi yêu cầu cái nữa
em ở chỗ tôi sẽ với mỗi nhóm thì tôi sẽ
yêu cầu riêng cơ mà nóng lạnh còn bé
trước mắt thì mọi nhóm thì tuần sau sẽ
nộ của tôi chạy vụ không giao diện
mỗi tuần một
một giao diện ạ
ở trong giao diện với nó đắt khách hàng
và giao diện với amin khác nhau mà các
bạn không cần phải làm chung đâu
thì các bạn cứ làm Riêng ơi Không ạ
có trường hợp nào mà máy mình chạy ngon
mà tải về không chạy được thì chắc là
tôi sẽ liên hệ với ông thôi để mấy ông
thử quay video demo tôi xem hoặc
teamview đúng không ạ Để tôi xem qua lại
cho like chị
gọi video để tớ xem qua mạng trên máy
ông chạy như nào rồi không chạy được
chứ không phải kiểu vẽ đâu Họ bé Nguyễn
chưa hình dung lắm nhỉ ví dụ là sự giống
như tôi vừa cho mày không xem ấy thì đây
là sản phẩm để mua đấy Đây đây là cái
đây Đây là một khung giao diện thì mua
này các bạn thấy thì ra là sản phẩm này
có thể đơn giản nó không bấm được trong
chỉ này thôi đúng ạ sản phẩm này cố định
đấy nó HTML thuần mà HT pro CS bạn ấy
em bị méo những không hình dung đoạn
mạch
thì hơi khó giải thích nhỉ rồi chúng nó
HT mà là Thuận thôi để mà về sau các bạn
sẽ có bao nhiêu sản phẩm các bạn đổ ra
In dùng pp để in ra bấy nhiêu sản phẩm
đấy thôi ngọn
chắc là tôi cứ nói thế trước mắt đã để
mà tuần sau tôi dậy mấy ông sẽ dễ hình
dung hơn chứ
anh nói cho cái khung này thôi nghĩa là
các bạn chưa cần phải code TP vội đâu
đúng ạ
khi con Na con tuần sau nữa tôi mới
người yêu cầu các bạn làm sale đê xong
rồi sao còn ghét tao tưởng mày chung mỗi
tuần tới sẽ yêu cầu các bạn làm dần dần
dần để mặc các bạn chính các bạn hình
dung dần trước
à mà không giao diện nữa Nhưng phải có
xe at rồi chứ không HTML thôi mày ông
Nếu không có mỗi mình cái đít thì mày
không sao Nhìn được cái đi
ở giao diện có hlcs trong có vẻ hoàn
chỉnh Ừ để mô
nó giống như cái phải giống như trang
vừa rồi giống hệt cái gian này
em chẳng qua là sản phẩm mày không bấm
được vào thôi à
à à
ở đâu ạ sản phẩm mà không bấm được vào
xem cái này HTM xe hết thôi rồi chưa
Linh này có thể không bấm được cho nữa
không có chọn tất cả những link được
không bấm được thế biểu tượng mày đưa
tao không quan trọng với ông là biểu
tượng đâu đấy
Ừ ok chưa ạ
ờ ờ deposit thì tôi không Yêu cầu phải
ông đâu tôi tôi nói là không cần đẹp này
không cần gì đó mà đúng ạ nếu không làm
thô trung thu cây cũng được giống như
hồi tôi chưa Bố cụ làm dzậy mấy ông sẽ
về chưa bố cục như nào Mày không làm
kiểu như thế cũng được không sao bạn ạ
Ừ tôi không yêu cầu mấy ông về cái vụ
tao diện em à
Dù sau này muốn sửa Thực ra là cốt các
bạn thì về sau Các bạn thấy về sau tính
năng các bạn mà thấy kiểu thấy không phù
hợp thì các bạn được phép sửa để quyền
các bạn nhưng các bạn các bạn cũng phải
tự trách nhiệm tự chịu trách nhiệm bằng
được đấy Khi mà giờ sử mà deride anh cần
gì rồi tự nhiên các bạn lại không biết
cách phân bố thời gian các bạn này đi
sửa cốt để mà các bạn tự nhiên có vấn đề
gì cốt lỗi thân thử các bạn mất quá
nhiều thời gian để sửa thậm chí bị trễ
để lại thì đấy cũng là lỗi các bạn đúng
ạ Ừ thì ah nói chung và tôi tôi từng lưu
ý cái lưu ý có người nhắc lại được cho
tôi vụ hôm nay tôi lưu ý cái gì không ạ
từ hôm nay tôi đi Hủy cái dòng chữ viết
hoa đúng ạ
anh không còn nhắn lại cho cậu đi
à À không Chẳng có điện chẳng biết nhắc
lại được cái gì nữa rồi bạn tên là đúng
rồi không được Sửa D về đúng rồi đấy mấy
ông chỉ cần nhớ cho đúng mỗi cái đấy
thôi một cái đấy thôi nhá
Còn toàn bộ những cái khác với ông đấy
là đồ ăn của mình không tôi chỉ có giới
hạn cho mượn tôi đang giới hạn ông ấy
ông ấy không được phép dùng cái công
nghệ gì đó còn ngoài những cái cái này
ra thì bị Ông làm cái gì là việc của mấy
ông mấy ông già sửa là không cho khách
hàng vào xem sản phẩm cái gì đó mà Mấy
ông giải thích được cái vụ đấy Chẳng hạn
giống như hồi trước có sinh viên của tôi
chẳng hạn sinh viên bảo là em không muốn
khách hàng có tính đăng ký kiểu thế em
muốn khách hàng nên đọc được sản phẩm
luôn không cần đăng ký ạ Không sao
anh đấy đấy là quyền của em ngủ ngon
nhưng mà nếu mà trang web của ông có ít
tính năng quá chắc chắn điểm ông sẽ
không phải dùng với điểm nữa đi nhưng mà
tôi nghĩa sẽ sẽ đánh giá là sẽ bị thấp
hơn đúng không ạ
anh không kế website trong có phải là
nói sai nhưng nó nó code trên máy tôi
đấy Nếu không truy cập được vào đâu
Ừ nếu không truy cập vào này xem ở đâu
đấy cô trên máy thôi mà
nhưng mà không hiểu lý do bạn nghĩa là
mấy ông làm được tính năng gì
Ê mấy ông thích có tính năng gì
cho tôi tôi dậy cho mi ông đầy đủ tính
năng thêm sữa Xóa các tối thứ
và làm tính năng giỏ hàng đăng ký đăng
nhập các thứ thứ mấy ông muốn làm thêm
tính năng khác nữa Thì đấy là quyền với
ông mày không làm bất cứ cái gì cũng
được
đúng không ạ Mấy ông ghét anh menu trên
với ông đẩy nó xuống dưới này nó sẽ cháy
phải thì tôi không quan tâm đúng ạ Nhưng
mà khi mà bảo vệ đoán khi mà tôi hỏi mấy
ông phải giải thích được không bao giờ
được trả lời mấy câu là em làm cho vui
Hay là em muốn tạo sự khác biệt tặng sự
hấp biệt đấy mà khiến trải nghiệm người
dùng tệ hai người dùng cảm thấy không
dùng được
Ừ thì đẻ trong các chết nó thể nó thế
thôi đúng không ạ đi
à à
Ừ
ông kia lại hỏi cái câu Tôi vừa trả lời
rồi à
Ừ ok Còn Ai thắc mắc gì nữa không
ừ ừ
vợ chồng tôi cứ bị nước xuống dưới lại
nhé xin lỗi
Ừ ok tiếng Trung Hà
buổi đầu
từ tương đối giải quyết được một vài
thắc mắc rồi yên tâm mà tôi sẽ có
livestream
1212 bội nữa có thể thế Trước hôm bảo vệ
gì đó
khi tôi còn đang nghĩ là việc à Nếu mà
chuẩn ra các bạn sẽ phải có bảo vệ thử
cơ nhưng mà
cộng đồng nhà thùng bia cho bảo vệ thư
bảo vệ thưởng mức sử
a23 buồn hơi sợ tôi Tôi sẽ cân nhắc
Ông Hà Ông kia cũng hỏi thêm câu nữa khá
được này tim không hợp nhau thì tách tim
ờ ờ
khi tim không hợp nhau ở đây tôi thôi
quên chưa chia sẻ với ông đó là ờ
cha mẹ ông nghĩ thế nào là việc ở ông
làm việc với người yêu của ông được
chúng nhỏ mới yêu
ở hội chợ ở tôi từng yêu bạn rồi nhà hồi
đã học cùng lớp đấy
bộ phim bé ông nghĩ làm việc hiệu cùng
nhau với người yêu thì nó có lãng mạn
không hay không
áo kiểu có động lực hay văn văn văn học
ở Thái sợ tôi từng làm đồ án với cả
người yêu và cả thằng bạn cũng khá thân
ở trong lớp 7 nữa được người bạn kia đã
nói đây chia tay hỏng họ có hư không tôi
tự làm mấy thằng bạn kia thì đúng là tôi
về sau tôi không chơi với nó nữa Thật
bởi vì vậy mẹ cái tác phong làm việc nó
giờ chán Nếu mà tôi lại chưa từng làm đồ
án cùng với người yêu
khi mà tôi còn bị ngược lại còn tệ hơn
rất nhiều
Ừ tôi làm việc đồ ăn với người yêu cũ
ông thầy Tôi ghét tôi và với bạn đấy
theo kiểu đã thay biết là nhiều cũng
luôn nhưng mà ạ Thầy biết tình tôi vẫn
gặp biết tính bạn đấy và kiểu cảm thấy
kiểu
xe ga hai đứa này vẫn có thể là việc
được với nhau lên à vẫn cho phép như thế
à mà béo biết kết quả nhé hả Bây giờ tôi
vẫn làm rất là bình thường tôi vẫn rất
ghét bạn ạ Nhưng tôi vẫn làm rất bình
thường
bộ phim
- là mấy ông không có quyền thắc mắc gì
cái việc là yêu hay ghét thì đây rồi
mình làm việc em phải ra tác phong của
làm việc mình sẽ không có kiểu bị bị
chậu cây suy nghĩ gì đó đây
Ê mấy ông phải nghĩ bài toán về cái lớn
hơn đối ngoại ý
10 cái người mà khiến nó Tôi ghét vé Cốt
và Pi thon và cả thậm chí là tôi ghét
toàn bộ những đồ Apple là không phải cái
bạn mà tôi vừa đề cập mà là cái bạn mà
tôi tán mãi không nô
a cho tôi nói cho cái đấy chuyện tình
trò chuyện tình vãi chưởng tôi xin chia
sẻ sau Nhưng mà cái bạn vừa rồi thì tôi
chỉ khóc ghét bạn tính Bạn ấy vì bạn lấy
được vô tư quá thôi nhưng mà ừ
anh nói chung là tôi vẫn làm việc được
với bạn đấy
ừ ừ
em làm việc
làm việc từ mấy ông không nên để tình
cảm chi phối
anh vay ít và ít nhất và yên tâm là
Ê bà bạn kia cũng sẽ phải như thế với
ông còn nếu mà Mấy ông cảm thấy lại ông
nhắn tin bạn kia bạn ơi Không thể trả
lời các sự phân vân thì sẽ
ở kỳ thi sẽ báo lại với tôi thì tôi sẽ
cân nhắc về cái nhóm đấy chứ không ạ
ở Việt Nam mình phải cố gắng đã còn bạn
kia mà thái độ lại hay là bơ hay vân vân
thì sẽ khác
Em tán không đổ mà ghét thì đương nhiên
là không không không đúng mà mà tôi tán
đủ rồi nhưng mà nói chung là nó bị
thế còn gì
Em không biết dùng từ nghe nào thôi tôi
kệ mấy thằng bạn rồi mấy bạn tới cho
biết ông từ Nga nói chung à đại Khái ra
kéo nó khiến nó tôi cay đắng theo kiểu
lại tôi từng thay đổi mình về một người
con gái đấy cùng thì
nhìn không phải người ta không đổ quan
trọng người ta không đổ ra mì cay
anh còn không thì không ca Yên Thế
sữa chưa tách bạch thì ai chẳng từng thế
tôi từng thế rất nhiều rồi đi
ạ Và bây giờ chuẩn khoa tâm sự à
Ê mày cái tâm sự tôi xin phép chia sau
nha Lại banh lan man quá
Ừ tôi đã bảo là đổ không phải không đâu
ở đâu ạ
là đủ rồi thì mới có chuyện để nói mấy
người cai mình ghét
khi sự thiếu nếu lỡ dàn người ta từ chối
mình xong rồi hết thì nó chẳng có gì để
cay ghét ở đây cả
Ừ đúng rồi mình sẽ tạo kênh disa đây
anh em đang làm đồ ăn hay nhưng có mỗi
mình em Cốt
anh làm sao yên tâm là cái vụ này cũng
khó thể cũng có thể có vài bạn sẽ bỏ
cuộc thì kiểu là áp lực vân vân hoặc có
vấn đề gì đó
khi họ đơn giản chán cốt thôi cũng có
thể đúng ạ Các bạn cũng sẽ có trường hợp
phải là một mình nhưng mà lúc đấy thì
mình sẽ yêu cầu Cả nhóm các bạn sẽ làm
cậu nhẹ hơn do nhóm khác vân vân Nói
chung là chỉ cần ra đồng muối sản phẩm
đâu mà đông ạ
anh không làm đồ hắn vô đít code phòng
nước
nói chung là tôi đã để link mời công
khai thì ông nào cũng thể vào được nhưng
mà tôi sẽ tạo kênh riêng chỉ có mỗi
những cái bạn mà có đăng ký để tôi mới
cho bạn ấy vào vào cái cây người Thôi
cái này ra ông làm à vào chỉ rất là xem
được mỗi cái kênh thông báo của thôi nó
cũng khai thôi à
Ừ đúng rồi tôi sẽ dạy các bạn giỏ hàng
lưu và season chứ không dậy và lừa dp2
lưu vào trong Cookie không lưu lại trong
local storage
khi hay tin một người mà tìm được nhau
thì sao Ý bạn là sao nhỉ yêu cầu cập từ
nhau ngoài đời chứ
à à
anh làm sao để yêu bạn cùng lớp ông này
giờ thì không nên yêu Đông Nghĩa
Vợ à
có gì
bộ nông nghiệp là gì Các bạn quên rồi
chỉ nhớ mỗi Đồng nghiệp với con thấy
không nhớ có gì thêm thì
ba chú voi con thầy vợ bạn cái con gái
cơ quan
từ
ngày cơ quan đây làm chị dạy con gái mà
tiếp xúc mình hàng này nên tránh nói thế
Nói thế rồi Nhưng mà thực ra ngày cũng
có mùi lãng mạn nếu mới là sự ngày nào
cũng gặp no đúng không Cũng hay mà
Tình yêu là để trong trường hợp mà
ở trong trường hợp mà bất đắc dĩ yêu
kiều của ông gỗ lựa chọn nào khác còn
không có lựa chọn nó tháng tưởng cũng
nên hạn chế
Ừ thôi tạm bỏ Hôm nay thấy đâu nhé
ừ ừ
cô gái cùng lớp chính là gái cơ quan đấy
không còn mong gì nữa ừ
Ừ
đúng rồi Nếu mà giỏ hàng mà không lưu ở
dp thì lúc khách hàng thoát ra thì hoặc
cả đăng nhập phần thiết bị khác không ạ
thì sẽ mắt nhưng mà mình dậy cho các bạn
về việc đấy biết qua thôi chứ không phải
đấy là cái cách giải quyết tối ưu nhất
bởi phía các bạn có thể là lưu và DB
hoặc lưu đâu có auris các thứ thứ nhưng
mà đây dậy để mà áp dụng vào season thôi
ông ạ Ừ
Ừ để hiểu qua khái niệm về mạng và
season - chứ không không bảo là đấy một
cách giải quyết những kiểu bây giờ bởi
vì bình thường các trang web bây giờ
chỉ có một vài trang web thì vẫn còn áp
dụng thì cậu giữ gìn thôi còn không chủ
yếu thì sẽ lưu vào dp hoặc Lucky II
Ừ thôi các bạn mà hết thắc mắc của nhỉ
Thế thì tạm cái đục bù hôm nay nhá trả
bạn nhé chứ
à à